we are still waiting for a winner in the
Iowa Democratic caucus due to the
unprecedented technical glitches but
partial results from the state party
already contains some surprises with 71%
of precincts reporting former South Bend
Indiana mayor Pete Budaj
is in the lead just ahead of senator
Bernie Sanders senator Elizabeth Warren
is third right now former Vice President
Joe Biden who some thought could win
Iowa is trailing in fourth place just
ahead of senator Amy Klobuchar ed
O'Keefe is in New Hampshire where the
next contest is less than a week away so
and I guess the question is this how are
the candidates responding to these
latest results well good morning Gail
the Iowa caucus and the results they're
usually a huge boost for the winner as
they come into the New Hampshire primary
which is on Tuesday and so while we
don't have all the data so far to
officially declare winner it hasn't
stopped some of the campaign's for from
spinning the partial results in their
favor Thank You New Hampshire former
mayor Pete buddhahood celebrated the
partial release of the caucus results
I'm here humbled by good news that's
come over the airwaves today mindful
that we are yeah we can go ahead and
celebrate that for a second as did
senator Bernie Sanders in Iowa we
received more votes on the first and
second round than any other candidate
while budda judge has a narrow lead over
Sanders in the Iowa delegate count
Sanders is ahead in the popular vote a
new figure being released by the state
party for the first time but some reason
in Iowa having a little bit of trouble
counting votes all the candidates
acknowledge the party's bumpy start well
they should get all of the data it is
very unfortunate former Vice President
Joe Biden is set to place a distant
fourth I look forward to a campaign
Nevada and South Carolina and Beyond but
you know I like my chances as the race
remain unsettled Mike Bloomberg
announced plans to double his operation
and held his largest rally to date in
Philadelphia home to Biden's campaign
headquarters still Bloomberg's keeping
his focus on the president
I think the results from Iowa underscore
that we need a candidate who can build a
coalition broad enough to unite the
party and strong enough to go toe-to-toe
with Donald Trump the closer we get to
March 3rd Super Tuesday the bigger a
factor Mike Bloomberg becomes and today
for what we think is the last time those
four senators running for president have
to head back to Washington for the
impeachment trial Michael Bennett Amy
Klobuchar Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders tell us they plan to vote to
convict the president Anthony thank you